the case against Brett Kavanaugh is is
falling apart more and more with each
passing hour and the allegations are
just unraveling and the smear merchants
who concocted this character
assassination crusade are looking around
it seems for a way to jump off the
bandwagon before it's too late they're
like that gif and it is gift by the way
not jiff of Homer Simpson backing away
into the bushes that's kind of like what
some of the Democrats are doing I think
when you look at everything that's
happened when you look when you look at
everything that's happened with with
with this Brett Kavanaugh thing you see
all of the problems with the me2
movement kind of encapsulated in this in
this in this one thing now all of those
problems and they're very significant
problems the mutant movement they didn't
just rear their ugly head for the first
time this week you they've been there
all along but if somehow you never
noticed them before I think now anyone
with two brain cells can can see because
all of those all of the the problems
have been sort of illustrated in the
last one or two weeks enough that even
just this isolated by itself even just
the last one or two weeks I think would
be enough should be enough to discredit
the me2 movement and and maybe hopefully
you'll cause us to look away from that
and return some some some semblance of
rationality and sanity to the
conversation about sexual assault and
harassment because it is a very
important conversation and that's my
precisely my problem with the me2
movement is that the me2 movement has
ended the conversation about it didn't
start the conversation it hasn't
enhanced the conversation or facilitated
it it has ended the conversation because
we're not allowed to have a conversation
anymore about it with the me2 movement
now there's a narrative and all you're
allowed to do is stick to the narrative
you're not allowed to actually you know
ask any questions or make any points or
anything like that so hopefully now we
most of us can see that in fact I think
not again not just from the last two
weeks but but in general I think there
are at least there are at least six
significant problems with the me2
movement
and six good reasons why it should end
which isn't to say that our opposition
to sexual assault should end because I
don't know about you
I've always been opposed to it I didn't
need the me2 movement to tell me to be
opposed to sexual assault I've always
been opposed to it front from the
beginning so I'm not saying that should
end but this thing called the me2
movement should end and I'll give you
six reasons for that number one me too
does not allow sexual assault
allegations to be evaluated on a
case-by-case basis so the first and
biggest problem with the me2 movement is
that it is a movement and because of me
- every alleged instance of sexual
impropriety is lumped with every other
alleged incident in the instance and
they're all kind of mixed together into
this - and each separate allegation is
then not seen as a separate allegation
but as an element or ingredient in this
stew and that's a pretty big problem if
we're gonna get to the truth of any
particular case and if we're gonna be
fair to the accuser and fair to the
accused we cannot look at each case as
another plot point in an overall
narrative we cannot see you know Brett
Kavanaugh we can't see Brett Kavanaugh
in the context of this this movement or
this narrative you have to look at Brett
Kavanaugh as an individual person and
Kristine Ford's an individual person and
their case is an individual case that's
how it has to be evaluated Brett
Kavanaugh is not just the man character
accused of abusing the woman character
as if these are just broad sort of
archetypes no he's an individual person
and she's an individual person and their
situation is an individual situation
which has absolutely no relationship to
Harvey Weinstein or Bill Cosby or any
other famous pervert got no relationship
whatsoever they're not connected even a
little bit so when you say me - when you
say oh well this is Brett Cavanaugh's me
- thing you have just taken him and put
him alongside all these other guys when
there's they are not this is not some
comes conspiracy among all of them okay
he's completely separate situation you
know this week I've heard several women
say in the media in fact one of
Christine Ford's friends was interviewed
by CNN last night and she has no
knowledge whatsoever of this of this
situation
which actually should tell you something
the fact that she's a friend of
Christine Ford had never heard about
this before but you know she was saying
this thing that I've heard other women
say other you know women that are
supporters of the me2 movement where
they've said well you know I I don't
know Brett Kavanaugh is guilty but but I
do know that those kinds of boys you
know growing up I did know those kinds
of boys and I was aware of those kinds
of situations happening but see that you
know I'm sorry that you knew those kinds
of boy if we're talking about those
kinds of boys as in rapists and if you
knew about those kinds of situations I'm
sorry you know that's that's unfortunate
I'm sorry that you grew up around those
kinds of boys but but but but see that's
not how we can we don't that's the
problem we can't look at this situation
through that lens
Brett Kavanaugh is not a kind okay he's
not a kind of person he's just a person
and this thing if it happened which I
don't think it did he's not a kind of
thing it's just it's a thing we're
dealing with specific people and
specific circumstances it is impossible
to be objective and rational if we're
looking at it through a narrative lens
if we're looking at it oh well he's just
that kind and this is that kind of
situation no that's that's not right
second thing the second problem to me to
me to does not acknowledge the
possibility that women can lie as we
have established it is a problem when we
start making movements and narratives
out of our up out of out of our
opposition to sexual assault like we're
all opposed to sexual assault fine but
when you make that into a movement when
you make it into a narrative it's a
problem and it's even more a problem in
this case when you consider what the
narrative is telling us name
that women don't lie about these kinds
of things believe women is what the me
to Crusaders shout they say believe
women well no I don't believe women I
Got News for you I don't believe women
I don't believe men either I believe
individual people regardless of their
gender if there are good and empirical
reasons to believe them so no I don't
have a blanket policy of believing women
any more than I have a blanket policy of
believing men or a blanket policy of
believing you know people with brown
hair it just doesn't make it that make
that makes no that has no bearing their
their you know their biological sex and
their you know the their demographic has
no bearing on whether or not they're
lying so it's just the stupidest thing
in the world believe women what do you
mean but women lie just like men lie you
know men and women all people lie so if
you're gonna say well women don't lie
well of course they lie everyone lies
now whether or not a particular woman
has lied about this particular thing
well now we got a look at the situation
and come to that determination but you
can't make it you can't have any blanket
assumptions about which gender is more
likely to lie it just doesn't make any
sense so when you say and I've also been
told you know someone I saw someone a
Facebook link to an article and the
title of the article is women don't lie
about rape well you know I may as well
say that men don't rape just because
most men would never rape doesn't mean
that any specific man who was accused of
rape didn't rape just like just because
most women would lie about rape that
doesn't mean that every single woman who
says that she was raped isn't lying see
it's just this is a very obvious point
that the me2 movement has intentionally
obscured you know what is its dog this
is what it is I'll tell you it's dogma
okay when you have movements when you
have ideological movements what you end
up with is dogmas you end up with
essentially points of doctrine and you
just with with something like
this you cannot go into it with a Dogma
or with a doctrine and so one of the
doctrines of of the me2 movement is that
women don't lie which is which is insane
first of all but obviously when that's
your doctrine there's you can't there's
no way for you to you're not an Allah
you can't analyze the situation you're
not analyzing it what you're doing is
you're just taking it and you're
applying your doctrine to it and you're
making a proclamation number three me
too
equates every kind of sexual misdeed
with every other kind and so we've
already talked about how you know the
me2 movement equates all different men
you know equates every kind of man with
every other kind to all accused men are
lumped together and equated with each
other so that happens but then also
every kind of accusation every kind of
alleged sexual impropriety is lumped and
mixed together with every other so that
a woman who alleges actual rape is mixed
with women alleging inappropriate
comments or alleging that a man groped
them or alleging that a man came on to
them too aggressively or that a man made
awkward attempts at flirting you know
all of these very very different sorts
of things are put together and the me2
movement mixes them all together again
there's that stew and this is just
another this is me I'm mixing the stew
right now if you're not that's what this
is this is the me to stew but all of
these all of these things are mixed
together in the stew and it's just so
you can't make any sense of it but they
don't belong you know rape is one thing
so you've got like on the spectrum
you've got rape over here it's it's
obviously the worst kind of sexual abuse
one of the worst things in the world
that exists and so you've got that and
then way down over there you've got like
inappropriate comment or a man clumsily
trying to come on to a woman or floor
whether you know so that's all the way
over there and there in fact they're not
even really part of the same spectrum to
say you know to put them on a spectrum
at all is to insinuate that well if a
man is flirting with a woman he's only a
few steps away away from rape as if that
will logically lead to that which it
doesn't so there actually is no spectrum
in between these things there's that and
then complainant and there's a wide
cavern and a gulf and then over there
you've got flirting the problem with the
media movement is that they have created
this spectrum and they've put all these
things on to it and then they've also
kind of bunched them together so that
they're almost indistinguishable so
that's a problem number two number four
I should say I don't know how to count
number for the Mewtwo movement is
tainted by politics now it's true that
they've gone after liberal men in
Hollywood so give them credit for that
but it is they've also mostly left alone
liberal men in politics and so obviously
with this Cavanaugh thing this is 100
percent politically motivated and once
you know when you claim that you're on a
crusade against sexual assault once it
becomes apparent that your crusade is
politically motivated well then the
crusade is completely discredited so we
can even leave aside everything else
I've said so far this point alone is you
have discredit the mutant movement has
discredited itself by jumping on the
Cavanaugh thing that that alone because
because of because of the politics in it
because we all know that if this was
Merrick garland garland or if this was
any you know if this was any Democratic
nominee this none of this would have
happened we all know that and we also
know
that and this is not oh this is not a
what about thing this is not what about
ism but it's just pointing out the
political nature of the me2 movement
because then you also have Bill Clinton
who was very credibly accused of
brutally raping a woman and was also
very credibly accused of abusing many
other women in many different ways and
yet he still has not had his me to
moment as he because it's politically
motivated number five I think this is
really important to me to movement
infantilizes women now it's true of
course that there have been many women
who have been raped and and then have
come forward and they'd been shamed and
smeared for coming forward that's a
horrible evil thing horrible and evil
absolutely evil and those women are
victims and they're survivors and in
more than one sense but you notice how
now even a woman who's sexually harassed
or a woman who has to rebuff advances of
a man or will say even a woman who's
let's say you know groped or something
which is a horrible thing don't get me
wrong but but now even those women we
call them survivors they're survivors
you know Dennis Prager wrote a column I
think was in the National Review
yesterday where he made the point that
like it used to be
survivor meant that you survive the
Holocaust
okay survivor meant that you either you
survived you know cancer or something
but now a woman a woman hears an
inappropriate comment from her boss in
1973 and we say she's a survivor you
know it's just it's it's ridiculous it's
infantilizing number one number two it
is it is unfair to the women who are
actually survivors women who have really
been abused assaulted raped those women
are survivors as I said in more than one
way but once again you
this lumping together that happens and
so we talk about we say well the me to
survivors and we understand that when we
say that we could be talking we could be
talk about women who were raped we could
also be talking about a woman who you
know in 1987 had an uncomfortable
exchange with with a guy at work we
could be talking about that as well and
it's just it's ridiculous frankly and
also you know the other problem with and
this is part of the infantilizing where
we're not allowed to expect women to
take any responsibility for their own
actions and this is just a conversation
you're not allowed to have because of
the mutant movement but in some of these
cases you hear about cases where where a
woman is in an awkward situation but
chooses not to remove herself from it
like louis c.k says i'm gonna take my
pants off and start touching myself and
the woman and the women decide to stay
to sit there rather than just getting up
and leaving the room or even you know
the Aziz Ansari thing where a woman
comes up to the to the to his apartment
with him chooses to do these dip various
sexual things later says that she felt
uncomfortable and awkward but she didn't
want to leave well but that's you know
if we're not infantilizing people then
what we need to say is well in that
situation you need to just leave you
need to take some responsibility for
yourself and if you're not if you're all
if you're if you're uncomfortable which
I don't blame you for me uncomfortable
leave the situation but because of the
media movement we're not allowed what
I'm saying right now I'm not allowed to
say it even though we all know it's true
because we all think the same things
when you hear some of these cases you
think well why do you leave what are you
doing why don't you just pick Kitsch get
up and leave it's not to say it's not to
blame you it's not to say it's your
fault the man who's being a pig and
being discussed and he deserves a
hundred percent of the blame but if
we're actually trying to empower people
then we need to also say listen if
you're in an uncomfortable spot leave
and then the sixth thing is me to is
just mass hysteria and this just ties
back everything else I've said that you
know with the me to movement it's it
does not allow for a reasonable
discussion doesn't allow for a
discussion at all you're not allowed to
make any of the points that I just made
especially the last one about you know
about about taking responsibility and
being accountable for your actions
you're not allowed to say that you're
not allowed to ask very basic questions
because it's a stereo and that's what
hysteria is all about or you have to
jump on the bandwagon and pick up the
pitchfork and go in whatever direction
the mob is going if you try to say hey
well hold on a second if you try to you
know introduce a little nuance subtlety
to the conversation and say hey I agree
that there are some horrible things
happening to women we got to talk about
that but you know what about this point
well you're not allowed to do that so
when you take all these factors into
consideration and you see what happens
when they all come together and land on
a guy look what happened to Brett
Kavanaugh I think when you consider that
it's clear to me that the me to movement
just needs to end which again does not
mean that our opposition to sexual
assault ends I don't need the me to
movement for that I don't need them to
tell me that it's wrong I don't think
you do either but this thing that we
call the me to movement I think has way
overstate its welcome at this point and
it's doing more harm than good thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed